I know you guys are getting
to be pros by now.
But let's do one more example for
good measure.
This time the challenge
is to write a method.
Inside the class.
Movie archive.
And this method should take in a year
and a dictionary of movies, and
return an array of strings listing
the movies that were released that year.
To start us off I've written the shell
of our movie archive class and
this dictionary of AI themed movies.
Here in between the parentheses
defining the movie archive class
we'll write our function.
Let's call it filter by year.
Filter by year is going to take
in a year as a parameter which
will be of type Int and it'll also
take in a dictionary of movies.
Which will be of type dictionary and
that dictionary will hold
keys of type string,
the movie titles and values of type Int.
The release here.
It will return an array of movie titles.
So here we'll type our arrow and then
the return type is an array of strings.
Since we're going to return an array
of strings, we'll need to initialize
an array of strings to put our
filtered movie titles into.
I will go ahead and return that array so
we can quiet this compiler error.
The next step is to loop through
the dictionary that's passed in and
check each key value pair to see if the
release year matches the year passed in
as a parameter.
To loop through the dictionary
we can use a for in loop.
We'll call the value release year.
Then if the year parameter is equal
to the value of release year,
we add that movie title
to our filtered array.
Now our filterByYear method
should be good to go.
To call it will need an instance
of the MovieArchive class.
So here I'll initialize
a MovieArchive and call it myArchive.
Then I can call filterByYear
using dot syntax.
And of course the dictionary we
want to filter is AI themed movies.
And let's see what AI themed
movies came out in 1982.
And over here in the sidebar
we can see Blade Runner.
And if we try 2013 we get her.
That ought to give you
a good start on functions.
Be sure to complete the exercises for
more practice defining and
calling functions.
As always you can find a link to
them in the instructor's notes.
Next up, we'll talk about classes and
their properties and methods.